le seulement c'est un poisson qui
demeurent entourées de mystère à ce jour
on ne sait pas exactement pourquoi du
comment
il retrouve la rivière où il est né une
chose que l'on sait par contre c'est
l'espèce connaît un déclin dramatique et
nouvelle étude permet de mieux
comprendre à quel moment de leur grande
migration des saumons de l'atlantique
sont les plus vulnérables
le saumon sauvage de l'atlantique malgré
son extraordinaire combativité celui
qu'on surnomme le roi des rivières est
en déclin seulement 2% des saumons
reviennent aujourd'hui frayer dans leur
ailière natale autrefois il en revenait
5 fois plus comment expliquer ce déclin
à quel endroit meurt le saumon dans sa
migration vers le groenland
des chercheurs canadiens viennent de
publier la plus importante étude jamais
réalisée sur ces questions tout a
commencé en 2003 sur les berges de la
rivière cascapédia en gaspésie des
chercheurs de la fédération du saumon
atlantique capture des saumoneaux en
route vers le groenland les ministes
d'émetteurs afin de révéler leur passage
à des endroits clés de leur migration
les chercheurs ont aussi capturer des
saumoneaux sur les rivière restigouche
de même que sur la miramichi au
nouveau-brunswick en tout 2800
saumoneaux sont munis d'émetteurs un
effort sans précédent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour enregistrer les passages de
saumoneaux on installe également des
récepteurs acoustique ou sorties des
rivières et dans le golfe du saint
laurent est aussi invraisemblable que
cela puisse paraître les chercheurs ont
tendu des récepteurs entre les deux
rives du détroit de belle-isle au nord
de terre-neuve et dans le détroit de
cabourg au sud
[Musique]
on croyait jusqu'ici que le détroit de
cabon était le passage privilégié pour
se rendre au groenland
compte tenu des courants mais plus
maintenant les poissons pasdar au maroc
il ya eu très peu de taxis non je dirais
peut-être de détection de démarreur qui
était à des sanglots qui ont été
détectés sur auditoire cabot mais trop
d'erreurs ce temps ils sont pas de
centaines de poissons sont passés par le
toit de belle-ile donc je pensais quand
même particulier que les poissons se
dirige vers le nord leur cueillette
molière les chercheurs ont aussi
découvert que les saumoneaux
franchissent le détroit de belle-isle
d'un seul trait est tous en même temps
on croit que c'est la température de
l'eau tout déclencherait le signal au
porteur pour franchir ce détroit aux
eaux froides impressionnante de ce qu'on
voit ce genre de synchronisation dans
des espèces qui viennent d'être de
région tellement divergents que c'est
absolument et anderson à 800 kilomètres
c'est la distance moyenne que parcourt
un son mono entre sa rivière natal et le
détroit de belle-isle
mais combien survivront à cette première
étape de la migration qui dure deux mois
cette donnée était jusqu'ici inconnu des
chercheurs dans des bonnes conditions 50
% des poissons vont mourir avant
l'arrivée la mer du labrador
donc à part l'intérieur de deux mois
donc c'est quand même des moteurs est
importante
c'est une période assez courte et après
ça john locke prochaine 1h30 2h sur les
populations
on a affaire un autre 40 35% de
mentalité donc je pense la partie la
plus importante en terme de mortalité
c'est sans doute des deux premiers mois
dire qu'ils sont près des côtes elles
sont justes au large de dole isère à ces
endroits
l'adaptation du saumoneaux à l'eau salée
domaine que la présence de nombreux
prédateurs explique ces mortalités mais
en comparant les taux de survie des
saumoneaux entre les rivières d'origine
les chercheurs ont fait une découverte
importante
il meurt beaucoup plus de saumoneaux
dans les rivières de la miramichi que
dans la rivière cascapédia y reste
gauche comment expliquer cette
différence
[Musique]
les chercheurs ne peuvent plus ignorer
la présence de bar rayé
il s'avère que les bons rails et sur la
tour dans les religions aux prêteurs
pour frayer sur site de frais et
l'atrium deux frères correspond à la
période des raisons de saumoneaux dans
la baie des chaleurs de ben ali n'est
pas dans mes moments donc une des
raisons une des choses je crois que kim
est un corpus de l'éthique qui
s'approfondit
c'est quoi le rôle de la présence de
marié et la prédation sur les saumoneaux
qui pourrait expliquer cette différence
en déduire
les chercheurs rappellent toutefois que
le bar rayé n'est qu'un des nombreux
prédateurs qui guette les saumoneaux
dans la première partie de leur voyage
phoques gris foot bassin et d'autres
grands poissons sont aussi des
prédateurs voraces explique le forte
mentalité de saumoneaux la mer du
labrador
une fois dans ses eaux d'autres périls
attendent les saumons plusieurs mourront
anges mais si on sait encore peu de
choses sur les causes de ces mortalités
on sait cependant que le saumon
n'échappe pas au bouleversement rapide
du climat que connaît l'arctique
les chercheurs avancent que la fonte des
glaces pourrait diminuer la qualité des
proies du saumon comme le capelan ce
facteur contribuerait également à
diminuer les retours en rivière des
années 80 le regardais la qualité
d'énergie caméra captant c'était
beaucoup disent et quelques on trouve
maintenant de quatre ans est temps que
pied maigre a beaucoup moins de calories
par gramme de cap 5
qu'est ce qu'on trouvait il ya vingt ans
donc qu'un poisson mange capteur est
peut-être moins d'énergie qui lui
revient qu est-ce qu il est magique
qu'ils avaient y avait un temps donc on
voit toujours que même si la loi est
disponible ces patients eux mêmes
qualités de 3
[Musique]
en tout les travaux des chercheurs
canadiens auront duré 14 ans si cette
étude ne lève qu'une partie du voile sur
la migration du saumon
elle apporte en revanche des
connaissances inestimable sur cette
espèce
elle nous rappelle du même coup que les
longues migrations animales se font
toujours au prix de nombreux périls
[Musique]